many employees do you have 40 I'm going  to throw you out the [ __ ] window let  me explain why you need to have real  one-on-one conversations with these  people and ask them what drives them you  should have absolutely no problem on  this what you need to do is have the  humility to be an accountable leader and  try to figure out what each one of them  ticks with when you talk to them after  15 minutes each you may have a read of  like two of them are like completely  full of [ __ ] that's great you can fire  but you're gonna find that for 12 of  them the fact that you even give a [ __ ]  to care about what they care about  versus what you care about them  achieving for you changes [ __ ]  everything the second you realize you  work for those 40 people they don't work  for you watch what the [ __ ] happens with  this problem